[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Yep, as soon as I see movement knock him out, gotcha.
>> It's only 60 feet.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> No, that's not that far for me.
>> Finding.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Wait, do this shit around.
As this is our only birth transportation for now.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
Now the hatch.
>> He can't, it's paused.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Great.
>> Yeah, well, I didn't want to, didn't allow me to throw damage before rolling.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Way back.
>> Nice.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I can dash out the boat is actually.
>> Rolls can dash out the boat is actually.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Well, dash out the boat is actually.
>> Isn't bail a little faster?
>> I just saw, I just saw him come back to me, right?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> We'll go find some sort of anchor or something.
This ship has to be stopped somehow.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> I can't reach mouth this way.
You'll have to.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> So when I get closer to the ship, how yellow the mouth is turned.
Now this.
>> What?
>> Wings away.
>> Boy?
>> To the air.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> [LAUGH]
>> Wasn't plan to use that boat.
>> You get the tent moving again?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Can Malthus do a to be my good Spider-Man on the ship?
>> Yeah, I'll grab him.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> The minute one of them wakes up knocking him out.
>> You'll be falling.
>> I'm gonna die.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Can I grab him when he's like a passenger?
>> I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
>> What the?
>> What is that, it's a waste of it?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Tell me how does it feel?
>> Tell me.
>> Animal companions.
>> Animal companions, who had, who was the droid?
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Can him to the back?
>> Can him to the back ground first.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> If you right click the broken, we have arrows that tend to back.
>> We are quick, we're down.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
[COUGH]
[MUSIC]
>> All right.
>> I didn't mean to do that.
>> God, David.
>> How do you delete that?
>> Because I just need a role for.
>> There you go.
[MUSIC]
>> How the fuck do you get a fancy guy's like that?
>> That's what I'm saying.
>> No, like, I'm stuck with this purple.
Let me get something fancy.
[MUSIC]
>> You take your dice.
>> What?
>> Yep.
[MUSIC]
>> Shit stop.
>> Yeah.
[MUSIC]
>> Hmm.
>> Yes.
[MUSIC]
>> My whole screen was like first, I think it's reloading.
>> Well, shit, I could just tell you what I'm going to do.
>> Steve.
>> So, this thing's trying to reach up to us.
I'm going to take one more.
Yep.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to, what the fuck is going to run my back?
The one that's standing to my left, and I'm going to try to throw it in the crab's like,
pincer.
>> Just like clown, like the one to my left, directly to my left.
>> Don't throw giggle, don't throw the captain.
>> I'm not.
>> Yeah.
>> No, no, no.
>> It's all right, it's all right.
>> I'm the one, like, literally.
>> Yep, yep, that one.
>> I'm going to.
>> Yep.
>> It would be just straight, straight.
>> No.
>> They're still marked out, right?
>> Okay, that's it.
I was trying to tame him by throwing him some food.
>> What?
>> I'm just kidding.
>> It's going.
>> It can reach on its back.
>> Nice taming.
>> Hey, at least I tried.
>> I can't, I don't have.
>> I don't have speed to animals.
>> Only someone ate a crap, crap, crap, lunch.
>> I'm going to.
>> Sorry, Bob.
>> Yeah, like, you see the, does anybody else see the dice spinning behind his back?
>> Yeah, it's the crap sword.
>> Nice.
>> Trent check.
>> Okay.
>> All right, and it's going to be at a disadvantage.
So here it goes.
>> Well, I don't know what I expected.
>> Order consideration.
>> Sorry, Bob.
>> Do I have my phone?
>> Sure.
>> Why not?
>> I don't know.
>> Yeah, go on.
There might be some other damage I could take.
>> Okay.
>> Here.
>> Right, super cool.
I am not going to do that because one, I am weak, two, I know my roles, three, I am broken and I have disadvantage.
>> Okay.
>> There is the Mr. Steele.
>> Oh, there is.
>> I don't know how to hurt it, but you guys have weapons.
Here is what I am going to do.
It says it does one default to slightly damage and attack roles and on strike can roll a critical hit on 19 or 20.
It's up to them.
>> Who do you think?
>> I am giving it a brain shock.
>> Well, that's my turn.
>> There is a fight.
>> Why can't I grab my token?
>> Thank you.
>> Yes, my idea.
>> Why is that?
>> Here is the dude.
>> He is carrying the dude.
>> How many is what, guys?
>> Yeah, that was a plan.
>> Yep.
>> He is carrying the guy.
>> Oh.
>> I thought they would have a team that was trying to throw the one to feed him.
>> Yeah.
>> I am not using team points for that.
>> That's the updated rules.
>> The crawlers.
>> The crawler and arm are moving.
>> I am not using team points.
>> I was still playing.
>> If I said team.
>> I am not using team points.
>> Coming in fast.
>> Well, shit.
>> I am not using team points.
>> What is the layer?
>> Here.
>> I am not using team points.
>> Let me quickly check.
>> He will grab.
>> He can reach her.
( hello someone? notice me sorry )
( glass cracking up. the Abdullah show up)
(uh unbelievable beauty. where is the sound on why?)
Clear?
(I don't really do anything)
(I use my action to... )
(it's in water if you... )
(well I need to do action first)
(I need to head first to do the bonus action)
(oh so uh... I again just need to stay in the water to help come on them)
(so Baptiste needs no man?)
(yeah Roma you're gonna fly)
(yeah I'm gonna stay this... )
(I'm gonna stay... )
(yeah I'm gonna stay the same thing to Roma again and you allow don't resist and cast levities but he's just gonna stay like 10 fed above not anything else)
(why don't you cast levity on the crown?)
(what do this that gonna do?)
(yes I can barely lift up Roma)
(uh ways up to five pounds)
(yeah so Roma cannot move around but he can go... I can make him go up or down and I'm gonna make him above the water but in the range so that he can hit the... )
(well I'm also... remember I have the grapple hook wrapped around me so I don't know how long that rovers)
(oh that's why the fucking captain to figure out if we can calm this bitch)
(I wanted to do that but nevermind so I'm... did I use all of my movement to just stay a floor or can I move?)
(yeah)
(alright enter)
(what did they do?)
(if I make my elemental domain in its clutches does that help me escape?)
(alright just double check)
(attack!)
(I've got 4, 3, 2, 1, go)
(this is one y'all)
(I said that I'm getting a 6-1)
(don't... don't dead fish in dead crustaceans float when they're dead?)
(well actually it makes a lot of time for the rigor modus to hurt)
(well I'm not trying to kill... I've been trying to stay there)
(I've been trying to stay there rather than... )
(yeah)
(I'm trying to stay there)
(he's a big boy)
(get him left)
(get him left off his back)
(oh)
(by the way veil is distracting the crab, right?)
(so we're good for some time)
(alright)
(is the captain within reach like can I scoop him?)
(yeah)
(giggle the crown)
(I don't... I just want to grab him and be like listen dude how do you call him this fucker down?)
(can't he like carry or bring him above the water or something?)
(that shoot say less)
(what do I got on that?)
(a lot of things)
(uh I got a javelin let's do it)
(that is usually used to make people fall asleep by the way)
(how well how long is this javelin?)
(no but they're like five feet)
(so like)
(I could like poke him with it)
(okay well then shit)
(oh)
(yeah)
(yes)
(hmm)
(but I need to do that on my turn so yeah)
(you're there for a while)
(I'm just trying to figure out what I could... I'm gonna throw the javelin ass in so that way the sharp end doesn't)
(oh definitely did I do that?)
(then yeah I'm gonna poke his ass)
(that's a grassy)
(what the hell do we do?)
(we did he just woke up and started attacking us what the hell)
(what do we do how do you get him asleep?)
(you had some dude fly off with it I don't know what his name)
(he ran off like a little bit)
(I'm gonna stick the little end of my spear or whatever javelin I'm gonna be like here you go)
(okay)
(again?)
(I'm not me, babe)
(Jesus Christ)
(that'll miss)
(heh)
(you're gonna have to do that)
(no)
A
for
all my guidefried
Noice gave the grapple no
Holds down where
Sure!
What is one else?
Malf die beauty?
Malf die beauty on live 가去了
Malf die beauty on live 가去
Is 5th 1st!
Zlesha, " papakea"
is 5th is Fiveth is Fiveth is Fiveth is Fiveth is six
But...
Wah! Okay...
Are you really OZ?
Let me see.
Can I...
For once?
Wait, next chance.
Man...
Front or the one?
Finally!
Okay.
Okay, so just checking.
Currently, everyone is all good, right?
The Devil Food Users.
And what did the captains say to do to Bessie?
They're waking up.
Oh, the fat guy is the handler.
And I need...
Okay, so I'm gonna go to the fat guy and help wake him up or something.
Do I need my...
Do I need to roll to go there?
Or can I just move?
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
Sure.
So, 15 feet.
And...
Yeah, sure, 15 feet.
And what does...
What do I need to get him up?
Half of 15.
What's up?
Oh, oh, wow.
No, I dashed.
Okay, I fucking dashed.
Yes, I used everything.
I'm not relieved.
Yay.
Is this guy out?
That's all we gotta do.
Ah, shit.
Yeah.
Come, Bethy, down.
Why do we just checking day, both are tied up, right?
Okay.
Uh...
Yeah, lie.
Huh?
We're changing to X-Pna.
Okay.
Malphus?
Uh, no, actually, Bethy did.
Technically.
I mean, we're on the middle of nowhere and we don't see land.
Right.
So if we don't, uh, do you, are you gonna die of starvation or something?
Yeah, I'm gonna die of starvation.
Because if we die, you die as well.
All right.
You hear how navelly speaks of you and Bethy.
Is this really who you want to be?
I can feed you and Beth.
Roma.
Roma, do you have any food on you right now?
Where's Roma?
What you need?
I just need some food to give him...
Do I have treats?
Oh, I can't.
Yep.
Tell me what's your favorite thing to eat.
All right, all right.
Small fishes as it is.
Who do I give this to somebody?
It tells me to roll.
Um, doesn't tell me.
No, I can just keep making them.
Okay.
Two.
He wants a couple of trees for Bethy.
No, screw that.
I have animal handling.
I'm gonna try to give him the bestie.
Oh, my God.
Well, we're dying again.
I'm gonna try to give him the bestie.
No, I'll give it to the dude.
I tried giving him to the crab.
He said you like treats, so I'm giving it to him.
I'm gonna whisper to Bethy and say, "Do animal handling on the guy, not the crab?"
I'm gonna try to give him the bestie.
What?
I'm gonna be nice to you.
Can you help us out?
Make your own choice.
He doesn't respect you or Bethy.
We can treat you nicely, give you both food like we just did.
Just help us out.
Now, screw that.
You ain't gonna have to answer to nobody.
You can go out and do your own thing with Bethy.
I'm gonna get you a massage.
Oh, damn.
Yay.
What the hell?
We're dead dead.
I'm conscious.
I love this guy.
Do you think you can get me to take us back to the island?
We can wait.
Long rest or rest?
Well, how much time are we gonna need for Bethy to get her strength up?
I'm gonna ask that.
Let's get up here and just start hanging out.
Let's get to know each other.
We can have a bone.
My name's Bob.
We have the same letter.
Do you want to have a new name?
It's not like a chimney.
How about do you have a name that you would like to name yourself?
Well, then you can be Bethy.
We can just call you Bethy.
We can just talk to Bethy and then Bethy will talk to Bethy.
You already got me to use right now.
You look like a chimney.
I'm not a chimney.
What about Billy?
What name do you want to be called?
Can you be Bethy's senior?
You can be Bethy's senior.
I take 10 damage.
Oh, shit.
Sure.
Come here, big guy.
I don't worry.
I'm not a chimney.
Oh, shit.
Bob's going to think about the moment that guy bashed his captain's head out.
He's going to think about his nose.
Let's play rock pepper scissors.
I'm going to show him.
I'm going to show him a rock pepper scissors.
Can I have a like advantage because he's stupid?
I'll check the body.
I'll try using it to see if anyone picks up.
What are we doing, buddy?
I'll check the body.
Are you ready?
Hello.